- Here are my three
tips to reducing stress
the night before a test.
Tip one, stay physically healthy.
There's a tendency that the night before
you wanna cram,
you wanna stay up late,
you're stressed, you're anxious.
That's the exact wrong thing to do.
The night before you
have to get good rest.
You have to relax,
maybe meditate,
watch a fun show, laugh a little bit,
hang out with your family,
and eat a healthy light meal.
You don't wanna have stomach issues
as you go into the test.
Tip two, organize your logistics.
It's really important that
as you go into the test
that you have to worry
about as little as possible.
So the best way to do that
is to organize everything ahead of time.
Know where you're going.
If you have to print out something,
print it out ahead of time.
Get your pencils in shape
and sharpened.
Even your clothes ready for the morning of
so that you just have to
have nice night of sleep,
wake up, do some simple tasks
and then go to the test.
The less you have to worry
about that morning the better.
Tip three, stay positive and confident.
And perhaps the most important thing
is as you go to the test itself,
keep a relaxed and positive attitude.
If you're stressed, if you're anxious,
that's going to become a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
So take a deep breath, breathe out slowly,
and say I got this.